Film Courage: Is it crucial to have multiple
projects going at once?
Mark Sanderson, Screenwriter and Author: Yes.
Film Courage: Why?
Mark Sanderson: Because like salmon going
upstream, a few will get up there.
I mean you have to…one script is not going
to do it as I always say.
One script eventually does open something.
Like for me, my spec opened the door for assignment
work with the company, you know.
I continued on with that but if you just focus
your energy on one thing, it’s a lot…the
odds that…you have to be constantly…then
that was my problem I’ll share with you.
When I sold my spec, I didn’t have a follow-up
and that really was a problem because I thought
“Here I am!”
And there was no follow-up for awhile and
that was my mistake because I wasn’t thinking
in those terms.
You know, it was early on in my pursuit, I
just graduated from college and was not thinking
in that structured like…”Okay, what’s
my game plan?” and I knew a friend who went
to film school and he directed a movie that
he wrote but he didn’t have a follow-up
and they spent so much time on this movie
and it was a feature and he didn’t sell
it, it didn’t get picked up by anyone, he
paid money to show it in a theater and they…”Okay,
what else do you have?”
“Nothing.”
So you constantly (as I say in the book),
you have to have ideas, you have to have log
lines that you’re working on and then you
also have to have some treatments or one-sheets
which are a lot easier to do than write a
complete screenplay and then you also have
to have your screenplay that you’re working
on.
But constantly when you go into a meeting
with your spec that gets you the meeting,
they’re not buying that spec they just want
to meet you and say “Oh, I can see your
ability” and then they say “What else
you have?”
And you don’t want that to be “Well, I’m
working on something and it’s going to take
me six months.”
I’m not going to see you for six months?
Or You’re not going to be on my radar for
six months?
You want to say “I have this other thing.”
You don’t want to bring a suitcase full
of scripts but you want to say “I have this
other thing.”
“Oh?
Well after the meeting, send it over.”
BAM!
You know what I mean?
You have to have multiple projects in the
marketplace, I think at all times because
not all of them and maybe not one of them,
but that’s what you’re up against is to
be…I don’t want to say a machine but you
know you can’t be precious with “Oh, I’m
only working on one thing for five years.”
And if you have the luxury of doing that,
that’s great but you better have a day job
that pays.
I didn’t want to wait tables the rest of
my life.
So what motivated me to get out was to continuing
to write and create.
So yeah, I think it takes more than one project.
Film Courage: I know you do a lot of speaking
events, is that right?
Mark Sanderson: I do.
Film Courage: So when you have writers approach
you either afterward or even if you see them
at a mixer or whatever.
You know when people ask you for advice and
you give it and you can see that they are
disengaging because they don’t want to hear
the answer?
Mark Sanderson: Yes.
Film Courage: What are some of those points
when you’re talking and they’re saying
“How do I break into the industry?”
Mark Sanderson: Because their experience will
be different than mine which it will be but
their experience will be like “Oh its not
going to happen to me.”
And like I said multiple projects.
And so when people do that I say I just I
don’t want to expend any more time bestowing
any sort of advice because what’s the point.
Example: I did a favor for a friend.
Oh my friend wrote this TV pilot.
Okay, I’ll meet with him.
Now I consult in my off times I have a consulting
business but I only do it when I’m not working
because the real jobs are the assignment jobs.
So in the downtime I open it up and say shop’s
open.
So I thought I’ll do this as a freebie,
as a favor.
And a lot of times it stings you and bites
you in the you-know-where.
So I went to meet with this guy at Starbucks
and he brings in a giant screenplay.
And I say “What is this?”
And he says “It’s a TV pilot.”
And I go “OKay.”
And he starts dropping names of people that
I know that are going to give him an office
in the thing.
And I’m like “They’re going to give
you an office?
What about me?”
And so I say okay I’ll read it.
So I went home and there were (I’m not kidding
you) ten issues on every page from typos,
to format to whatever you want and so we met
again and I was really doing my friend a favor
and he had an excuse for every one and wouldn’t
listen and he said “Well, I’m going to
chop it in half and make it a thing.”
And I’m like “Okay, interesting.”
And still went on and on dropping these names
about some of the people I know are some how
going to bring him in and give him a desk
and an office and I was just like “I can
only do so much.
Good luck to you.”
And maybe I’m wrong?
I doubt it but okay.
People who don’t want to listen it obviously
shows their ignorance.
And it’s not…I’m not trying to be malicious
I’m just trying to say “Hey, I wish someone
had done that to me.”
Then it would save me a lot of time and time
is what keep clicking away.
When you make mistakes why spend all this
time making mistakes when you can do it right?
Or go down this path?
Everyone has to learn, hopefully they do.
But yes I’ve experienced that where people
just tune off and it’s like “Huh?
Okay?”
Film Courage: And is that around the time
when you say it’s going to take several
scripts, always have multiple things so if
somebody wants to see one?
Mark Sanderson: Yeah, that’s why.
I went to talk at a high school.
My friend is a teacher to their film class
and one of the kids raises his hand and goes
“Have you written any big movies?”
Phew…how long do we have on this?
So we went through the thing and you could
just see all of this.
They’re not going to…but the few film
nerds which I was one growing up, after it
was over they came up (three or four came
up) and said “Oh!”
And they wanted to look at a script and talk
to me directly.
Everybody else couldn’t wait to leave and
I just thought “Huh?
Interesting?”
I was making films when I was their age, you
know?
Doing that and they can do whatever.
Maybe they weren’t interested, that’s
okay.
But I always say you’ll be humbled.
If you’re not humble now, the craft and
the business will humble you eventually where
you say “Oh, my one script.”
And then you learn that after 35 screenplays
either you’re still learning which should
be and it takes a lot to get one.
That’s why the multiple projects thing is
important, to have multiple projects going
at each time and that’s not to say you have
to write two projects but always have something.
You finish one, you’re working on another,
don’t leave these long gaps of nothing and
you’re out there.
And my spec that I sold it took seven years
but that wasn’t my only thing I had.
I wasn’t running around town with this one
spec.
I continued on doing other things.
I was in a sketch comedy show.
I was doing proactive things at the same time
but the only problem is that once it’s sold
I didn’t have a specific spec like in the
same genre where they could say “What else
can I look at?”
Where things weren’t ready.
You know that’s important too to have those
other things ready because like I said if
you have that meeting and they say “Oh send
over something,” you don’t want it to
be six months later, you want it to be immediate,
immediately.